when you do an intentional pass
interference the best outcome is
they didn't realize it was past
interference and that sparked
controversy that sparked a sense of
urgency that the nfl had to do something
about it the competition committee
which is always afraid of everything
afraid of its own shadow afraid of
unintended consequences afraid of this
afraid of that
they ultimately got pushed into a corner
to
adopt replay review for past
interference which is a great idea in
theory it was
horribly executed and i think if
anything that makes the competition
committee even more concerned now
about what to do for this situation and
i say all that miles because
the ravens have proposed and this was
weeks ago
the addition of a booth umpire an eighth
member of the officiating crew who would
be in the replay booth
who would have access to everything we
see and would operate
as a member of the crew who could talk
to the referee
just like when we see two or three of
them getting together on the field and
talking they're trying to figure out
what did they see
this is the best way to avoid a disaster
this makes sense and as the ravens
argued in the paperwork that they
submitted
it's happening at some point we may as
well do it now so with the competition
committee
and i think people tend to overstate
what
power and influence the competition
committee has because the owners
routinely ignore them the competition
committee has proposed this modified
replay official enhancement where there
are certain objective things that the
replay official can help with
it's not going to fix the tommy lewis
niquel roby-coleman situation it's not
there's still no fix for that and that's
the problem because miles my concern is
this there's eventually going to be a
next
officiating debacle with booth umpire or
sky judge or whatever we want to call it
you got a chance to avoid it with
enhanced replay
official duties you don't
that's why they need to ignore what the
competition committee has suggested and
embrace
the ravens proposal i loved what you
wrote about this mike because you
basically said it's a half measure
what the competition committee is
proposing it just reminds me of breaking
bad no
half measures you should always go for
the full measure when you have the
opportunity
to get the full measure and i think that
they should have gone with the full
measure
after that play with nikhil roby-coleman
and tommy lee lewis which i gotta say
frankly as a selfish person was one of
the most
consequentially good plays in nfl
history for me because
i was covering the rams that year for
the rams i got to go to the super bowl
and partly because
of that play so i love that play i think
that play is great i am so glad they
didn't call pass interference i had a
fantastic week at the super bowl
even though that game uh was not one to
write home about so
i think having said all of that they
clearly need to do
something to make sure that something
like that can't happen
and when you are just making this half
measure of yes
will enhance you know the replay
official give him more duties than he
already has
and that that person that official
already has a lot of things to do
so basically you're trying to say yes we
think we can keep the status quo
as it is but just tweak it a little bit
when really there's a clear and obvious
solution
that they're just for whatever reason
don't want to do yet
and they're gonna have to do it
eventually so why not just do it now rip
the band-aid off
get it right you do realize that if you
continue to remain gainfully employed
with us there's a pretty good chance
you'll go to the super bowl regardless
of which teams are in it and your
chances of going
are enhanced are enhanced
if you quit mentioning a certain book
i'm going to start keeping a list like
ryan on the office
if you keep mentioning that book you
will be asked to stay home and mine the
store while the rest of us go to the
super bowl so it's up to you
as to whether or not you keep mentioning
a certain book that's your litmus test
to get to the super bowl so uh
that's good that's good well done well
played um
look here's the reality for the nfl
legalized gambling
or gambolyzing is sims calls it from
time to time
to the point where i almost say it from
time to time
is spreading more than 20 states now
have it eventually there will be 30 35
40. i think the maximum is 44 because
frankly
there's only 44 states that currently
have the basic
lottery things that we've had for
decades in other states and i remember
what a controversy that was in the 70s
with
the daily number and the scratch off
lottery tickets and oh my god here we go
it's a slippery slope well
when gambling is in 30 35 40 states
when these calls happen it's going to
have a much
different reaction than just
team in new orleans lost and was robbed
of its shot to go to the super bowl so
senators and congressmen from louisiana
huff and puff there's the three pigs
again
this is going to be people who have lost
money
wagering on the team that ultimately
ended up on the wrong side of that bet
because of the bad call even if the same
team wins you know one of the
worst calls of the past 15 years was
when scott green who's now the head of
the nfl referees association just flat
out blew a call
after the steelers had taken a lead
against the chargers late in a 2008 game
in november i think it was a late
afternoon game
blew the call should have been a
touchdown for the steelers after the
steelers took the lead late
steelers would have covered they didn't
cover millions of dollars wagered
illegally for the most part changed
hands
you make that tens if not hundreds of
millions of dollars
that change hands legally and something
like that happens
what the nfl needs to ultimately fear
miles and i know i've mentioned this
before because you made fun of me
for it they need to fear the creation of
an agency
by the federal government charged with
the oversight
of professional sports for the purposes
of ensuring the integrity
of wagering no different than the sec
not the football conference the federal
agency that showed up
five years after the stock market crash
in 1929. before that
no sec so an extreme example like that
is the kind of thing that gets the nfl
into a huge problem so they need to do
what they can now
to get their affairs in order or someone
else is going to do it for them and
they're not going to like the rules and
regulations that apply
yes i made fun of you because you went
all the way back to the sec instead of
just saying the consumer financial
protection bureau which is something
that you know more people remember
because it happened way more recently so
you just gave me the opportunity
to do that again um i i think that
you're absolutely right
that they have to take care of this
themselves and that's why we're really
both saying
you can't do the half measure just do
the full measure
i you know it's just one of these things
that i think is probably a societal
problem
at large sometimes we just don't want to
make any change
because we're so satisfied with the
status quo and maybe even satisfied is
the wrong word
but we're just content or complacent
really to stick with
everything that we know let's say a high
school musical song stick with the
status quo you probably don't know what
that is
gosh wow yeah high school interesting
it came to my mind i'm sorry i don't
even know why but i shouldn't have done
that but my point is
i think when you have a society that
just loves tradition
and loves to keep things the way that
they are
it's hard to sometimes just say no we
really need to change this
because change is coming whether we like
it or not so we really should be
proactive about it instead of reactive
but at this point the nfl is already
reactive
because of that video that we just
started this segment with because
something like that
should not should never happen in a
conference championship game
and it really has a lot to do with
determining the outcome now
you can say if you're rams fans and some
of them may get in my mentions later
that that didn't really determine the
outcome because i've made that argument
before myself i know it but
look when you have that situation you
really should do everything you possibly
can to prevent
it from ever happening again i think the
fact that their solution from two years
ago
failed so badly makes them hesitant to
go out on a limb again
and also there is a financial component
it's one thing to add more duties to a
current employee which is what the
competition committee proposal will do
it's another thing to have to go out and
hire a whole new crew
of extra officials to serve as the booth
umpire or the sky judge and even as the
nfl
is swimming in coins like scrooge mcduck
they don't want to give any of those
coins away if they can avoid it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights from nbc sports